eher googelte nach dem perfekten mord
bis heute bestreitet er aber seine
verlobte umgebracht zu haben
christian f krankenpfleger 35 jahre alt
gilt mit einem iq von 113 als besonders
intelligent ist selbstverliebt und hat
eine gestörte sexualität seine verlobte
maria böhmer starb 2012 ihre leiche
wurde im wald von einem pilzsammler
gefunden
daran haben eine frau gewesen das ist es
kommt doch mal her
ich habe ihn stetig sehen und gehen noch
vom schenken euch sagen freunde
raus hier das ist ein menschliches
skelett habe ich die notruf angerufen
christian f cell loch an der stelle
gebündelt haben dann soll er ihr das
nachthemd ausgezogen und ihren
verlobungsring abgenommen haben
dann hat er die leiche mit lösch kalk
überschüttet den spaten mit dem er das
loch gebuddelt hat lässt er zurück laut
staatsanwaltschaft sprechen 18 indizien
gegen den angeklagten unter anderem soll
christian er vor der tat nach dem
perfekten mord gegoogelt haben
an der leiche von maria wurden spuren
von medikamenten gefunden
außerdem soll der angeklagte heimlich
eine andere frau geliebt haben
bislang bestreitet christian f den mord
was er allerdings zugegeben hat er hat
die leiche seiner verlobten im wald
verscharrt und mit löschke übergossen
hintergrund dieser vergrabene aktion war
dass er seine verlobte am morgen tot in
der gemeinsamen wohnung aufgefunden
hatte sie hatte medikamente genommen
weil sie am vorabend rückenschmerzen
geplagt hatten und bauchschmerzen
diese medikamente hatte der angeklagte
im bezirksklinikum mitgehen lassen wo er
gearbeitet hat und für den angeklagten
bestand nun das große problem dass sie
sich im rahmen des todes
ermittlungsverfahren dahingehend hätte
erklären müssen woher frau war diese
medikamente hatte ein gutachten über den
angeklagten im prozess verrät dass sie
ein mann mit zwei gesichtern ist
die gutachterinnen beschreibt die
nationalisten mit selbstwertproblemen
unter neigung zur verdrängung von
konflikten
nach dem 43 seitigen dokument ist ein
selbstverliebter mensch der unter tiefen
selbstzweifel leidet sollte vor allem
leidenschaft maria gewesen sein
sie schloss ihr studium ab er scheiterte
an zwei chemie prüfungen für die
gutachterinnen ist christian f voll
schuldfähig heute gegen 15 uhr wird ein
urteil vor dem landgericht regensburg
erwartet wenn im mordfall der der
perfekte mord sein sollte mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren